.
Cool.
V.a. das hier ist cool.
Es zischt so richtig raus.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Lachen *
Hast du das gesehen?
Man sieht gar nicht richtig,
wo es rauskommt.
Feuer und Eis - Natur pur auf Island.
Auf Island
haben Isabelle und Steff Felix
eine Ferienlodge mit drei Apartments
gekauft.
Euer Zimmer.
Mit einer Bautruppe vergrössern sie
die Lodge um drei weitere Häuschen -
sog. Tiny-Häuser.
Geht's?
- Ja. Was ist wohl in den Paketen?
Den Innenausbau stemmen sie allein.
Er ist schon zufrieden mit mir -
es bleibt ihm ja
nichts anderes übrig.
Bei jeder Witterung
checkt Steff dieses Wasserloch
auf ihrem Gelände.
Für unsere drei Apartments
haben wir Wasser,
aber für die drei Tiny-Häuser nicht.
Denn für ihre Wasserversorgung
sind Landbesitzer auf Island
selbst zuständig.
Auf Mallorca übernimmt der
erfahrene Gastronom Otmar Gemperli
mit seinem Freund Gabor Balogh
ein Restaurant.
Nach intensiven Renovationsarbeiten
feiern sie Eröffnung.
Wer hat die Spaghetti?
Eine anstrengende
und emotionale Zeit.
(Alle) Ho-oh!
Diese fordert ihren Preis:
Otmar muss sich
um seine Gesundheit kümmern
und zieht sich für einige Wochen
in die Schweiz zurück.
Plötzlich war es,
als hätte mir jemand
den Stecker gezogen und gesagt:
"Stopp, es ist genug."
Statt das Restaurant samt Leitung
an Otmar übergeben zu können,
muss die bisherige Besitzerin wieder
Tag für Tag vollen Einsatz zeigen.
Gabor bleibt auf der Insel
und arbeitet weiter - ohne Otmar.
Ich vermisse ihn sehr.
In diesen acht Jahren
waren wir immer zusammen.
Papa, jetzt kannst du Vollgas geben.
- Halt dich fest!
Familie Tscharner
will in Florida heimisch werden.
Innert Monaten hat sie ein Haus
erstanden und eingerichtet ...
Mal sehen, ob die Kinder hier
auch Rucksäcke haben.
... die älteste Tochter eingeschult
und gleich mehrere Immobilien
gekauft.
Ihre Geschäftsidee:
Ferienwohnungen vermieten.
Eine Wohnung an Toplage
will Melanie zuerst neu einrichten.
Hier ist genug Platz,
um es so zu machen.
Ein weiteres Objekt
ist ein Haus in Alligator Point,
das die Tscharners
zu einem Beach House umbauen wollen.
Es ist alles unter Wasser.
Aber jetzt ist es ...
* Donnergrollen *
Ich glaube, wir müssen reingehen.
Doch hier
sind die Renovationsarbeiten
viel aufwendiger als gedacht.
# Uf u dervo, yeah.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Es ist Ende Januar in Island.
Die Nächte sind lang, die Tage kurz.
Die Schweizer nutzen
das Tageslicht aus - pausenlos.
Ihre Lodge
war während der Saison gut gebucht,
aber im Winter
kommen weniger Touristen.
Ich muss kurz überlegen,
wann die nächsten Gäste kommen.
Wenn ich es
richtig in Erinnerung habe,
kommt in einer Woche wieder jemand.
Wir reinigen das Zimmer
immer sofort,
damit es bereit wäre,
falls jemand spontan buchen würde.
Dann kann der Gast
gleich einchecken.
Anfangs Sommer, so hoffen sie,
können sie die Tiny-Häuser vermieten.
Der Tourismus auf Island boomt.
Auf ihrem Grundstück
wäre Platz für noch mehr Häuser.
Wenn wir noch grösser werden,
können wir es zu zweit
nicht mehr bewältigen.
Dann müssten wir
jemanden einstellen,
der uns hilft.
Das bedeutet allerdings
Personalkosten
und es wird komplizierter.
Wir möchten das in den ersten paar
Jahren eigentlich allein machen.
Sie hatten ein bisschen
schmutzige Finger.
Gemeinsam etwas aufbauen,
davon haben sie geträumt.
Komm, ich helfe dir.
- Nein, geh.
Pass auf, hier ist es arschglatt.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Noch ist ihr neues Leben
eine einzige Plackerei.
Jetzt suchen wir irgendwo ...
... noch ein Plätzchen.
Langsam ist alles voll.
Es ist etwa sechs Wochen her,
seit der Müll
das letzte Mal abgeholt wurde.
Es wird langsam etwas eng.
Es ist ja schön,
dass es jetzt wieder schneit,
aber das heisst für uns,
dass die Müllabfuhr diese Woche
wahrscheinlich wieder nicht kommt.
Seit Wochen schon
arbeiten der Eventmanager
und die gelernte Kauffrau
am Innenausbau der Häuser.
Wände täfern, Heizungen,
Böden, Bäder und Küchen einbauen.
Ach, du bist mir einer!
Und das nicht nur in einem,
sondern in drei Häusern.
Willst du bohren?
- Nein.
Wenn das Holz so hart ist,
lieber nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Soll ich sie halten?
- Ja.
Mallorca. Es ist Ende Juni.
Immer mehr und mehr Touristen
strömen auf die Insel.
Die Mittelmeerinsel
ist Otmar Gemperlis Sehnsuchtsort.
Aus gesundheitlichen Gründen musste
er ihn vor zwei Monaten verlassen.
Irgendwann hat es auch Gabor
nicht mehr ausgehalten
und reiste in die Schweiz,
um Otmar zurückzuholen.
Es ist speziell,
wieder hierher zurückzukommen.
Ich habe noch nicht
richtig realisiert,
dass wir wieder hier sind.
Otmar ist wieder gestärkt.
Jetzt will er definitiv Fuss fassen.
Rechtzeitig zur Hochsaison
ist er mit Gabor wieder da.
Der zweite Anlauf soll gelingen.
Jeder mag ja ein Zuhause,
in dem man sich wohlfühlt,
wenn man nach Hause kommt.
Man will nicht immer
aus Kartons leben,
sondern irgendwann
alles eingeräumt haben.
Dann kann man
eine Flasche Wein öffnen,
wenn man nach Hause kommt,
zusammen ein Glas Wein geniessen
und einfach entspannen.
Schatz, ich gehe rauchen.
- Okay, ich komme auch gleich.
Otmar stellt hohe Ansprüche ...
- Komm, Schätzchen, komm.
... und neigt dazu, sich selbst
unter enormen Druck zu setzen.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen,
von nun an alles positiv anzugehen,
auch das Gute zu sehen
und nicht immer
gleich schwarzzumalen.
Ja.
Es war vielleicht alles
etwas zu viel:
die Auswanderung ...
... ein neuer Ort,
eine neue Wohnung ...
... der Umbau des Restaurants,
neue Menschen, eine neue Sprache.
Man kann sich nicht mit allen
verständigen,
obwohl es mit Händen und Füssen
dann schon klappt.
Es sind viele Herausforderungen,
an die wir vielleicht
nicht unbedingt dachten,
als wir das Ganze planten.
Aber ich gebe mir wirklich Mühe.
Dabei brauche ich
auch Gabors Unterstützung,
damit wir das Baby
gemeinsam schaukeln
und gemeinsam
in die Zukunft blicken können.
Ich freue mich, wieder hier zu sein.
Wir schaffen das gemeinsam.
Wenn etwas ist, besprechen wir es.
Wir blicken einfach nach vorn.
- Renaldo, komm!
Komm!
Gabor nimmt das Leben
wesentlich leichter.
Oh, mein Handy ist heiss.
Tschüss. Viel Spass.
- Tschüss.
Routiniert,
aber immer noch begeistert,
fährt Lily Rose
täglich mit dem Bus zur Schule.
Good morning.
- Morning.
Bye, Lily Rose, tschüss.
Seit drei Monaten besucht sie die
Elementary School in Crawfordville.
Heute kümmert sich Mario
nicht um das Haus in Alligator Point,
denn auf ihrem Grundstück
steht ihr jüngstes Projekt:
ein Wohnwagen.
Der ist zwar heruntergekommen,
dafür kostete er so wenig,
dass die Tscharners
zugreifen mussten.
Auch den Wohnwagen
wollen sie bald vermieten.
Wenn man die Investition
wieder reinholen kann,
geht das.
Es ist ja so kalkuliert.
Das haben wir in
unserem Businessplan berücksichtigt.
Ist es gut so?
Gut.
Wenn es gut ist, ist es gut.
Seit Kurzem nimmt
auch Tscharners jüngste Tochter
am amerikanischen Leben teil.
Ruby Sue darf Spielstunden in der
Wakulla-County-Bibliothek besuchen.
In einem halben Jahr erst
kommt sie in den Kindergarten.
(Frau auf Englisch)
(Kind)
Allein, ohne ihre Schwester,
ist es Ruby Sue langweilig geworden.
Hier ist endlich wieder etwas los.
(Ruby Sue) Green.
- Yeah, take the green.
Yes. - (Frau) Definitely
make sure you try.
Sie sind so herzlich,
so hilfsbereit und so lieb.
Das ist ein Phänomen,
das mich wirklich
jeden Tag aufs Neue fasziniert.
Highlight des Morgens
ist die Fütterung der Hühner.
Ruby Sue hat in der Bibliothek
schnell Freunde gefunden.
Vorher sagte sie täglich,
sie wolle zurück nach Gams.
Hier sei alles blöd.
Ihr Kinderhort und ihre Freunde
fehlten ihr
und Lily Rose ging von einem Tag
auf den anderen zur Schule.
So war sie mit uns allein zu Hause.
Darüber freute sie sich nicht so.
Aber jetzt ist es besser.
Ich fand einen Ort, an dem wir uns
mit anderen Kindern treffen können.
So hat sie Freunde gefunden.
Jetzt wird alles gut.
Seit dem frühen Morgen
sind Isabelle und Steff unterwegs.
Es windet schon recht stark.
Der Wind fegt über die Strasse.
Ihr Ziel: Akureyri.
Sie buchten eine Bootstour
und wollen Wale beobachten.
Es gibt immer wieder Gäste,
die uns fragen,
ob wir einen Ort kennen, an dem
man Whale Watching betreiben kann.
Und ... ähm ...
So kamen wir auf die Idee, an einer
Whale-Watching-Tour teilzunehmen,
damit wir unseren Gästen einen
guten Anbieter empfehlen können.
Wenn sie die Tour überzeugt,
wollen sie mit dem Anbieter
eine Partnerschaft eingehen.
Die Fahrt geht über das isländische
Hochland an die Nordküste -
eine einsame Gegend.
Für mich war der Winter in Island
immer die schönste Jahreszeit.
Dann sind am wenigsten Leute da
und das Licht ist fantastisch.
Man fährt ein paar Hundert Meter
und sieht gleich wieder
das nächste Fotosujet.
Man kann die ganze Zeit
Fotos machen.
* Majestätische Musik *
Ich hoffe, dass es
nicht allzu sehr schaukeln wird.
Ich stellte fest,
dass ich nicht so seetauglich bin.
Nach einer dreistündigen Fahrt
erreichen sie den Hafen von Akureyri.
(Isländisch)
(Englisch)
Bye-bye.
Wir fahren nicht bis ganz nach vorn.
Es macht viel aus,
wenn wir nicht bis nach vorn müssen
und bereits in dieser Gegend
Wale sehen.
Das ist natürlich cool.
- Mhm.
Hello.
- (Beide) Hello.
2 Std. dauert die Fahrt
auf dem Eyjafjördur.
Schau dir diese heisse Quelle an!
Dort oben könnte man baden.
Okay, aber ich glaube,
jetzt gehen wir runter.
An die Wärme. Also, sei vorsichtig.
Soll ich vorgehen?
Nein, es ist okay.
Der Fjord meint es gut mit Isabelle:
Das Wasser ist ruhig.
Das ist einer der ersten Tage
seit Langem,
an dem wir etwas unternehmen.
Es ist fast ein bisschen langweilig.
Ziehst du dir den Strampler an?
- Ja.
Ein bisschen rumtrödeln.
- Tu das.
Isa, Isa, komm, schau!
Hast du es gesehen?
Nein.
- Komm, schau.
Komm.
- Es schaukelt etwas.
Dort vorn - die Schwanzflosse.
Blick geradeaus nach vorn.
Dort vorn spritzt es gleich wieder.
Bombastisch.
Schöner könnte es nicht sein.
Es ist super.
* Verträumte Klänge *
Melanie ist unterwegs nach Panacea:
An der Forgotten Coast
besitzen die Tscharners eine Wohnung,
das Apartment
mit der sagenhaften Aussicht.
Es ist das erste Objekt,
das sie vermieten.
Ich würde nie selbst
in einer Community leben wollen,
aber für Ferien
ist die Wohnung der Oberknüller.
Ich selbst finde es jedoch schöner,
einen grossen Garten zu haben
und allein zu sein.
Langsam beginnt das Geschäft
zu laufen -
und zum Geschäft
gehören auch Angestellte.
Hailey ist ihre erste Mitarbeiterin.
Zusammen wollen sie
das Apartment reinigen.
Hä?
(Melanie)
Huh?
Äh ...
Das Bett ist unberührt.
Der Gast war wohl gar nicht hier.
Es ist alles noch so, wie es war.
Ähm ... Das war die Person,
die mir schrieb,
dass sie auf dem Weg hierher
einen Autounfall gehabt habe.
Sie fragte mich,
ob ich ihr einen Tag erlassen
bzw. gutschreiben könne.
Ich sagte: "Ja, klar."
Sie meinte,
sie käme erst am nächsten Tag an.
Nun sehen wir,
dass sie gar nicht hier war.
Unterstützt von Mario
hatte Mel das Apartment
innert wenigen Wochen
neu eingerichtet - im Boho-Style.
Es war richtig schön,
hier zu arbeiten
und Mittagspause zu machen.
Das ist richtig schön.
So ...
Endlich: als Unternehmerin
in den USA Geld verdienen.
Ein Erfolg.
Es war schon etwas Besonderes,
das Ganze zu starten.
Irgendwann merkten wir, dass wir
vor lauter Stress, Arbeit usw.
ganz vergessen hatten, mal richtig
auf unseren Erfolg anzustossen.
Dann gingen wir
mit den ersten Gästen lecker essen.
Es war schön, als sie sagten:
"Es ist so schön hier."
"Die Natur
und die Gemütlichkeit der Wohnung
liessen uns den Alltagsstress
total vergessen."
Das war für uns das schönste
Kompliment und der schönste Start.
* Melanie schreit erfreut auf. *
Der Tag hält für Melanie
eine weitere Überraschung bereit.
Oh!
* Sie lacht. *
Unverhofft ist auch Winky hier ...
I don't ...
- Ah!
... die einstige Besitzerin
von Tscharners neuem Wohnhaus.
Sie ist meine Ersatzmama.
- Mama, yes.
Es war wirklich
Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Alright, I love you.
- I love you, thank you so much.
Bye-bye.
- Bye, Winky.
Es ist unglaublich,
wie viele Leute wir
in dieser kurzen Zeit kennenlernten.
Sie sind extrem herzlich
und kommen auf einen zu.
Wir wären ja nicht so.
Wir sind immer noch Schweizer,
etwas schüchtern und denken:
"Nein, wir müssen nicht unbedingt
mit denen reden."
Oder wir trauen uns nicht.
Sie kommen immer auf einen zu.
Jeder spricht uns an und sagt:
"Hey, ihr seid doch die,
die in Winkys Haus wohnen."
Das weiss ganz Sopchoppy.
Es ist wirklich lustig.
Deshalb lernten wir
so viele Leute kennen.
Im Restaurant Brisas del Mar
hat Geschäftsführer Otmar den
ersten Arbeitstag nach der Rückkehr.
(Corinna) Hallo.
Español? Deutsch? English?
Corinna Hauer,
die bisherige Besitzerin,
musste während seiner Abwesenheit
erneut die Führung übernehmen.
Das Restaurant läuft prächtig.
Die Stimmung jedoch ist gespannt,
besonders zwischen Gabor und Corinna.
Gracias.
Dass auch Gabor vor zwei Wochen
in die Schweiz geflogen ist,
hat sie enttäuscht.
Alle mussten mehr anpacken.
Bitte sehr.
Schatz, es ist unser Restaurant.
- Noch nicht.
Corinna meldete Gabor beim Arbeitsamt
ab und suchte neues Personal.
Ohne Arbeitsbewilligung aber
darf er nicht wieder anfangen.
Danke.
Sie war sauer.
Sie sagte, weil ich gegangen bin,
hätte ich selbst gekündigt.
Das fand sie nicht korrekt.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es korrekt war oder nicht,
aber mein Gefühl sagte mir,
dass ich bei Otmar sein muss.
Servicepersonal auf Mallorca
ist nicht einfach zu finden.
Und nach Otmar war nun auch Gabor
für unbestimmte Zeit weg.
Es war ein ganzes Stück länger
als gedacht.
Die Verteilung
ist dann ja ganz anders
und letztlich
machte ich alles wieder allein.
So, Tapitas.
Zeit für ein klärendes Gespräch
fehlt,
schon bald beginnt der Mittagservice.
Ich muss kurz
das Besteck fertig machen.
Die vier Mädels an Tisch 14
kriegen gleich etwas zu essen.
Tisch 8 ist neu.
Die müssen erst mal begrüsst werden.
Hallo zusammen.
Die Karte.
Bitte schön.
Möchtet ihr schon etwas trinken?
Wir wollen nur etwas trinken.
- Ah, okay.
Servierst du das mit Röhrli?
- Ähm ...
Womit? Röhrli?
Ah, Strohhalm, okay. Ja.
* Otmar lacht. *
Manchmal kann Schweizerdeutsch
ein kleiner Stimmungsheber sein.
Am Tag nach der Bootstour:
Die Auswanderer haben die Nacht
in Akureyri verbracht.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Da fährt einer mit dem Velo.
* Isabelle lacht. *
Der hat Spikes an den Reifen.
In Akureyri gibt es
ein Einrichtungsgeschäft.
Eigentlich kaufen Isa und Steff
das Inventar vielfach online ein.
Also, ich ...
- Was brauchst du?
Wir haben Folgendes notiert:
Teppich, Schuhlöffel ...
... und Boxendeckel.
Mhm.
Und den Rest haben wir eigentlich.
Denn Einkaufsfahrten
sind lang und somit kostspielig.
Dort hinten.
Aber einen passenden Teppich
für das grössere der Tiny-Häuser
haben sie online nicht gefunden.
Ah, hier ist er.
- Einer ist noch da.
Ist das das richtige Mass?
- Er ist 40 mal 2 m gross.
1,40 m.
Doch, das passt.
- Fürs grosse sollte es passen.
Wieder etwas erledigt.
- Hast du alles?
Ja.
- Die Schuhlöffel?
Ah!
Und ab nach Hause.
Allerdings nicht auf direktem Weg.
Islands Wildnis hat den Naturburschen
Steff schon immer angezogen.
Sei vorsichtig!
- Ja, ja.
Der Wasserfall, den er am Vortag
entdeckte, lässt ihn nicht mehr los.
Soll ich dich festhalten?
Gib mir dein T-Shirt!
Ich schaue eigentlich
nicht so gern zu,
wenn er sich in Gefahr begibt.
Der Hot Pot, die heisse Quelle,
liegt etwa 10 m
über dem eiskalten Fjord.
Mir ist nicht besonders wohl
bei dem, was er gerade macht.
Aber es ist super.
* Isabelle lacht. *
Er reizt immer alles aus,
was möglich ist.
Aber er weiss immer, was er tut.
Die Füsse spüre ich noch.
- Wirklich?- Tipptopp.
Frisch gebadet.
Ich bin wieder sauber.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Über 30 °C hingegen
ist es auf Mallorca.
Während der Zimmerstunde
wollen auch Otmar und Gabor
einen Moment durchatmen.
Es ist heiss.
Die angespannte Stimmung zwischen
ihnen und Corinna belastet beide.
Es kann sein,
dass wir ihr das Gefühl gaben,
dass wir sie im Stich liessen.
Ich hatte auch ein schlechtes
Gewissen gegenüber Gabor,
weil ich ihn hier
alleingelassen habe.
Das war für mich auch nicht lustig.
Ich hatte auch ein schlechtes
Gewissen gegenüber Corinna.
Es ist vieles vorgefallen
und wir haben
unterschiedliche Ansichten.
Das müssen wir wirklich klären.
Jeder hat seine eigene Wahrheit.
Aber alle wollen das Gleiche:
Das Restaurant soll florieren.
Einmal mehr steht ein Gespräch an.
Otmar will es positiv angehen.
Okay?
- Ja.
Wie das geht,
kann er Gabor abschauen:
täglich eine Portion Leichtigkeit.
* Ruhige Musik *
Um 15.30 Uhr
hat Lily Rose Schulschluss,
eine halbe Stunde später
ist sie daheim.
Hi, Lily.
Thank you.
Hast du noch Hausaufgaben?
- Mhm.- Mhm.
Dank des Umzugs
vom Rheintal nach Sopchoppy
hat Lily Rose das Glück,
zweisprachig aufzuwachsen.
Eigentlich
verstehe ich schon fast alles.
Es kommt sehr selten vor,
dass ich etwas nicht verstehe.
Name first.
Beim Englisch-Büffeln
lernt auch Melanie dazu.
Was gibt es hier noch?
Weisst du noch eine Bezeichnung?
Squirrel, okay.
Schau mal da oben, hier steht es.
Ja, das passt rein.
- Squirrel.
Du bist so ein kluges Mädchen.
Ja, für mich ...
Es gibt einzelne Wörter,
deren Bedeutung ich
auch nicht kenne.
Dann muss ich jeweils
den DeepL Translator benutzen,
weil ich gewisse Wörter
auch nicht kenne.
Ein grosses,
liebevoll eingerichtetes Haus,
Mama und Papa, die für sie da sind -
den beiden Mädchen
ist es wohl in Florida.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Mama kommt auch gleich.
Gute Nacht.
Sind die Kinder im Bett,
kümmern sich die Eltern
ums Gästemanagement.
Ich schrieb der Frau ...
- Ah ja?
... dass ich gesehen hätte,
dass sie gar nicht im Apartment war.
Nun hat sie zurückgeschrieben.
Sie bedankt und entschuldigt sich.
Sie habe sich einfach
nicht mehr dazu aufraffen können,
hierherzukommen.
Sie habe mich
nicht mehr stören wollen,
weil sie mich bereits
wegen der Rückerstattung
der einen Nacht belästigt habe.
Oh!
- Ja.
Wir hätten ihr
noch mehr erlassen können, aber ...
Ich fragte ja,
ob ich noch etwas für sie tun kann,
aber sie antwortete nicht mehr.
Sie hat jedenfalls
total nett geschrieben.
Es ist also okay für sie?
- Ja.
Ihr Apartment an der Forgotten Coast
ist zu drei Viertel ausgelastet
und bei den Städtern aus Tallahassee
beliebt.
Wir waren wirklich überrascht,
wie viele Buchungen es innerhalb
der ersten drei oder vier Tage gab.
Ja.- Damit hätten wir
wirklich nicht gerechnet.
Wir machten ja keine Werbung,
sondern veröffentlichten es
nur auf Airbnb.
Wir waren total überrascht.
Nun freue ich mich,
wenn unser nächstes Projekt,
das Saloon-Ranch-House
in Alligator Point, fertig wird.
Wenn das auch noch läuft,
kommt das Ganze ins Rollen.
Dann kommt die Realität
und wir können wirklich sagen:
"Jetzt haben wir unser Business."
Das ist einfach mal ein Anfang.
- Ja.- Mal sehen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Den ganzen Vormittag schon
fegt ein warmer Sturm
über den Osten der Insel.
Schnell ist der Schnee
weggeschmolzen.
(Englisch)
(Flüsternd) I'm sorry about this.
- He was waiting for me ...
Auf dem Land schauen die Nachbarn
auch unangemeldet vorbei.
V.a. im Winter haben die Leute Zeit.
Das gilt für Steff nicht.
Wenn er am Arbeiten ist,
lässt er sich ungern stören.
Noch sind nicht alle Küchen
eingebaut, noch fehlen die Bäder.
Ich sollte für die Gäste da sein,
aber gleichzeitig
muss es vorangehen.
Ich bewirte sehr gern Gäste,
aber ich mag es nicht,
dabei ständig denken zu müssen:
"Mach jetzt endlich
diese Hütte fertig!"
Das ist das Problem bei mir.
Daher lasse ich sie einfach machen
und arbeite weiter.
Isa macht das perfekt.
Doch Steff weiss:
Auf Island nimmt man sich Zeit,
auch wenn man keine hat.
Brauchst du mich?
- Ja.
Also gut, ich komme.
Ich gehe kurz zu ihnen.
Be careful.
(Frau)
Sie wollten schon früher kommen,
aber ...
(Steff)
Farmer, Bóndi.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Es ist schon lustig,
wie neugierig die Leute sind.
Das ist das Dorfgespräch:
"Das müsst ihr euch ansehen,
die haben da ..."
Uns macht es natürlich extrem stolz,
ihnen die Häuser zu zeigen,
und es ist schön,
miteinander zu philosophieren.
So lernt man die Leute aus dem Dorf
kennen.
Er macht alles schmutzig.
- Ja, dort auch.
Dort ist es egal.
Der Besuch kommt nämlich wie gerufen:
Der Nachbar ist nicht nur Bauer,
ihm gehört auch
ein kleines Baggerunternehmen.
Und v.a. kennt er sich
mit Wasserquellen aus.
(Isländisch)
(Englisch)
Oh, that will be great.
- Great.
Nachbarschaftshilfe
ist im dünn besiedelten Island
eine Selbstverständlichkeit.
So, die Arbeit geht weiter.
Wir haben immer das Glück,
im richtigen Moment
die richtigen Leute zu treffen.
Im Dorf hilft jeder jedem.
Er wohnt ja auch bei uns.
Ab und zu befreit er
auch unsere Strasse vom Schnee.
Das ist für uns schon ...
Man hilft einander, wo man kann.
Ab 10 Uhr bereitet das Brisas-Team
den Mittagsservice vor.
Hallo.
- Guten Morgen, Mariyan.
Nach einem Gespräch
ist die Stimmung wieder gelöst.
Corinna kann endlich kürzertreten.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, hallo.
Es ist so weit ja alles aufgebaut
und unter Kontrolle.
Daher: alles gut.
Ich bin beruhigt.
Ein kurzer Gang aufs Arbeitsamt
und Gabor darf wieder arbeiten.
Jetzt mache ich
die Bestellung bei Moyà.- Ah ja.
Dort bestellen wir unsere Liköre,
also die alkoholischen Getränke,
und alle Zutaten
für unsere hausgemachte Sangria.
Wir fangen einfach mal beim Gin an.
Bombay Sapphire haben wir,
und den Hendrick's.
Wir brauchen immer nur eine Flasche
und keine auf Lager.
Otmar muss nachholen,
was er während seiner Abwesenheit
verpasst hat.
Kaffee wurde diese Woche
schon geliefert.
Kommt er auch einmal pro Woche?
Manchmal kommt er und manchmal
nicht. Er ist ein bisschen spanisch.
Einen Moment.
Mittlerweile
ist schon fast Ende Juni.
Wenn es mittags voll wird,
wird es meistens sehr schnell voll.
Dann habe ich wenig Zeit,
um Dinge zu erklären.
Es wäre besser gewesen,
wenn ich Anfang der Saison alles
peu à peu hätte erklären können.
Aber nun muss ich mich
konzentrieren, wenn es voll wird.
Daher erkläre ich Otmar in
ruhigen Phasen so viel wie möglich,
damit er so bald wie möglich weiss,
was zu tun ist, wenn ich weg bin.
Endlich den Traum leben -
den Traum
von einem Restaurant auf Mallorca.
Ich habe hier zwei Biere.
Die offeriere ich euch.
Okay.
- Gerne.
Gracias.
- Sehr gerne.
Ich bin Otmar.
Ihr seid ja Stammgäste hier.
Ja.
- Freut mich sehr.
Seit 30 Jahren.
- 30 Jahre schon?
Klaus und Claudia.
- Otmar, freut mich.
Ich hoffe, ihr bleibt uns treu.
Wo hast du mein Brot?
Bitte schön.
- Danke schön.- Guten Appetit.
Das nächste Mal
servierst du nicht mein Brot.
Du musst für dich schauen.
- Okay.
Das Schicksal des Brisas del Mar -
bald schon liegt es ganz
in Otmars und Gabors Händen.
Guten Appetit.
- Danke.
Das Liebespaar wird nun Tag für Tag
auch unter Stress
zusammenhalten müssen.
Wenn man zusammen arbeitet
und zusammen lebt,
ist man immer sehr nahe aufeinander.
In Zukunft müssen wir das abstimmen,
damit jeder seine Freiheit hat,
denn 24 Std. aufeinander zu sitzen,
ist nicht gut.
Irgendwann kann man sich
nicht mehr ausstehen.
Wenn man sich liebt, geht das schon.
- Ja, aber ...
Wenn man sich liebt, geht das schon,
egal, wie viele Stunden
man zusammen ist.
Aber es ist ja trotzdem auch ...
Wenn wir einander lieben,
geht das schon.
Ja, das wäre schön.
- Ja.
Es  w ä r e  nicht schön,
sondern es  w i r d  schön.
Das muss so sein.
So, jetzt müssen wir weitermachen.
- Ja.
Noch den Hintern abwischen.
Bin ich immer noch schmutzig?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Schieben!
- Ja, ich schiebe ja.
Er kommt ja auch. Schieben!
Nein, der Kühlschrank ist geöffnet.
Hoppla.
Ich habe keine Lust,
die auch noch zu überfahren.
Im Nu hat Mario den Wohnwagen
in Schuss gebracht,
die Schäden repariert.
Jetzt will er ihn
am Rande ihres Geländes parken -
bereit für Gäste.
Tscharners
haben viele Geschäftsideen,
doch nur eine Philosophie:
Sie bieten das an,
was ihnen selbst auch gefällt.
Warte mal!
Ja, es ist okay, es geht.
Es ist okay.
Ja, ja, es passt.
Wie weit nach hinten fährst du?
- So weit es geht.
Etwas nach vorn
und dann etwas näher ran.
Schau mal nach,
ob dort noch Wurzeln sind.- Ja.
Ich glaube, es ist okay.
Tipptopp.
Wir mussten noch
eine Stromleitung verlegen.
Sie ist knapp 100 m
vom Haus entfernt.
Wir verlegten mitten durch den Wald
eine Freileitung.
Vielleicht
verlege ich sie mal unterirdisch,
wenn ich Zeit habe, zu baggern.
Eine Wasserleitung
möchte ich sowieso mal verlegen.
Jetzt müssen wir das anders lösen
und mehrere Schläuche
aneinanderhängen.
Aber Strom ist schon mal vorhanden.
Das ist so ziemlich das Wichtigste.
Das Wohnmobil bietet Platz
für eine sechsköpfige Familie.
Melanie war einmal mehr
für das Interieur verantwortlich
und sie gab dem Wagen auch den Namen:
Turtle Shell in the Woods.
Wir können ja hier Ferien machen.
Ich freue mich,
dass wir das geschafft haben.
Nun können wir ihn auch vermieten.
Hier kommen jeweils Rehe vorbei.
- Ja, man sieht jeweils Spuren.
Man sieht überall Rehspuren.
Es ist ein tolles Erlebnis,
hier zu übernachten
und die Tiere zu sehen.
Passt auf! Tut das nicht!
- Nein.
Wartet kurz!
Nicht mit dem Feuer spielen.
- Das tut ihr nicht.
Eure Schuhe sind ungeeignet.
- Das macht Papa.
Hinter dir.
- Oh!
Dort!
- Dort auch?
In der nächsten Folge
ist es mit der Ruhe vorbei:
Kannst du mir nicht helfen?
Bis jetzt musste ich dir nie helfen.
Ich hätte ja
gar nicht mitkommen müssen, oder?
Aber wenn du da bist, kannst du
schauen, dass es nicht wegdriftet.
Tscharners führen ihre erste
professionelle Bootstour durch.
Ah, da.
(Englisch)
Das Haus in Alligator Point
ist endlich saniert.
Das Paar beginnt mit dem Umbau
einer weiteren Immobilie.
Auf Mallorca brummt die Hochsaison.
Die ehemalige Besitzerin
des Restaurants stieg definitiv aus.
Ich bin froh, dass das Restaurant
jetzt zu 100 % mir gehört.
Es ist alles gelöst und erledigt.
Die beiden sind umgezogen:
Von ihrer neuen Wohnung
schauen sie direkt aufs Meer hinaus.
Sommer auch in Island.
Bald schon kommen die ersten Gäste
für die Tiny-Häuser,
doch noch fehlt der letzte Schliff.
Trotz Zeitdruck
pflanzen sie 4'500 Bäume an.
Momentan ist einfach
nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt dafür.
Dort unten ist der nächste.
Die Quelle ist ausgebaggert
und gefasst,
aber bringt sie auch genügend Wasser?
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024
# Uf u dervo, yeah.